tried the cocaine and it was like uh
it was like all the drugs combined
with icing on and a cherry on the top
the taste of it i was married to the
pipe it was just the most beautifulest
feeling and taste and sensation
you can imagine
[Music]
marine where were you born i was born in
hmp-style women's prison in women's law
in cheshire
my mum was
a prisoner a teenage prisoner my mum was
undecided whether to
sign me for adoption or not
so she got released from custody and was
unsure whether to give me away um
so then i
was
seen by a welsh woman and a jamaican man
they looked at me seeing my big
beautiful
saucer shaped eyes they said and uh
they chose me so my mum told me
from very very young
that you didn't your mum didn't want to
give you away she wanted to keep you but
the circumstances what was going on
around her and i
her home life and whatnot she couldn't
keep me
she said um
it was born in distress as well i never
knew that what that meant so
i used to think about that a lot and
then at nights i tried to sleep but i
couldn't sleep so i'd be banging my head
off the pillow and hold my breath
to try and not wake up the next morning
because i thought wherever that place is
that's where my mum is
so i used to try and get there by
holding my breath
and my dad
he got raised very tough so his mum and
dad apparently didn't like him he'd let
him move he lifted it
and he had to run away from home and
whatnot so he was a very tough man so he
used to go to town on me a lot
beat me a lot with her
belts bamboo canes so my mum obviously
my adoptive mum she was beautiful
towards me but when my dad used to hit
me she used to say don't hit him around
the head
so that used to confuse me a bit she
won't say don't hit him she does say
don't hit him wrong head anyway 11 years
old
there's these blocks of flats opposite
where i lived
and he was this lady was about 16 and i
got speaking to him and stuff and i had
this games console like a computer
console
and um he told me he had some games for
it so we went to his house and he
he he said no i haven't got it
my mates got it over in the other block
of flats
so i went over with him and um it was
some old man like in his 50s
so i just didn't think he was right
anyway what's in the house
the guy just pulled me straight into the
bedroom pull his big wooden toolbox
behind it
and started just tearing at me with his
tongue or licking me
and stuff
so
he tells me clothes off and raped me
anyway so i was 11 i got raped
i went home shocked like
couldn't speak
next day come home from school
he sat in my mum and dad's house
so like i'm
i'm mortified
so he started talking to him he's
talking to my
mum and dad saying him oh yeah my mum
thanks you very much for helping her go
shop
going shop for yesterday do you mind
going shop for us i was like wow
i'm a mum and dad not said anything just
like talking to him like you know him so
i just thought wow
so i started this was happening for a
little bit
hopping for
all over the summer couple a couple of
couple of summers i got
i was getting raped till i was about
summer of
uh two years
i didn't feel i couldn't normalize it in
my mind i didn't feel normal i felt like
uh
i was from a different universe i didn't
feel
worthy of this earth because
i've never been no one had ever treated
me with any love and respect so far
with
genuine love and affection
what were the ways you found to cope
with all of that
i used uh butane gas i started on butane
gas when i was eight years of age
um i went into an empty house and it was
loads of these glue bags on the floor
and a tin of glue
so i've seen the glue bags so if i'm
going to try it so i put the bag inside
the glue and scraped it round
and started sucking on it and it just
sent me to like it was it felt like the
place where i should have been when i
was born
not this place so it was
a beautiful place it was hallucinogenic
it took me away
uh it was an escape so i didn't think
anything of it but i knew it was wrong
i was very confused growing up uh
i was trying to find my mum i used to
run away from home a lot
to try and find all i could think about
was my mum growing up
so then the the drugs were sort of
taking me there to try and meet her like
we have this
we have this invisible card what binds
us
and i could feel a pulling on it when i
was like 14
i started taking lsd
started taking ecstasy started taking
amphetamine
my drug use started getting a lot worse
as i was getting older
um i was taking more and more drugs so
when i got to
15 i was playing up in school i've been
expelled
i've been sent to a school like where
you need a bit of extra help for being a
bit of a nuisance in the classroom
so i went and i went there a couple of
times but by then i was selling drugs
for a girl after school so i was doing
that after school for money
to buy over drugs and experiment with
other drugs and then i was out in a club
one night we used to go to like the
ascendant conspiracy and all these all
these clubs and i was out in a club one
night and uh seeing this girl
and dancing on the dance floor and she
looked really pretty and dead fun and i
started chatting to her and then she
offered me to go back to where so she
lived local to me
she said to me um sat in her house she
said you've ever took cocaine
so i said yeah yeah but what i only did
is i've only tried it in joints in
nightclubs before because he'd like a
little spliff coke had been passed
around so i've never really tried it but
i was to kind of i was only 17 trying to
show off saying yeah i've tried it and
she came in with a pipe with the
photo with ash on it with a big piece of
crack on it it was white cocaine to me
so i
tried the cocaine and it was like
it was like all the drugs combined
with icing on and a cherry on the top
so i quickly became addicted to crack
cocaine i don't understand how
how it's gripped me but so much it was
so nice it was so the taste of it i was
married to the pipe it was just
the most beautifulest feeling and taste
and sensation
you can imagine
i was stealing i was stealing out the
city center i was shot lifting
i was going in and out of prison getting
recalled getting arrested for thefts and
whatnot
so how many times all in all you've been
in in and out of prison i've been to
prison probably
between 25 and 30 times
i used to go to prison
many times for thefts and
um i'd get very short sentences
but
in in fact it was very good for me
because i was a crack addict i was
skinny as a rake
so then little six week sentences used
to help me put on weight get my physical
self back in order and soon as i'd walk
into prison anyway i'd know everybody
everyone would be like yes you're back
on the wing buzzing
so uh i'd be
selling drugs on the wing for people
um
selling heroin selling
anything
tablets cannabis
how easy is it to get drugs in prison oh
it's very easy yeah very easy to get
drugs in prison i um
i was hanging around with the gang who
was at all the links and there were
always the right plugs and we was
getting throw overs off over the wall so
he was anywhere up to a kilo of cannabis
resin coming over
six mobile phones uh
steroids needles
subutex crack cocaine
cocaine
and so it does come over the wall it was
very very easy a lot of people in
prisoner spend a lot of money in prison
as well like there's people who go to
prison who have got money
and they start spending so what happens
is you give them say a quarter of
cannabis they give you 200 pound but
their girlfriend passes at your
girlfriend on the street
so it's very easy to get in a lot of
debt as well
so they've been times when i've been
asked to go collecting debts in prison
as well
like what um
say
hot watering people and whatnot but um
that didn't happen often
and uh also doing
like people say they want to see blood
so uh if someone says they want to see
blood off the head
so i and i knew that person who was
doing the hit on i'd say to them look
i've got to do a hit on you these wages
on your head
um
just let me let me tap your eye over
here like you're doing raptures with
your knuckles like that i'll pop your
eye open there'll be a lot of blood it
won't hurt
and um sometimes i'd have to do that it
was necessary so
the guy the kid would get out of trouble
and i'd get paid the wages as well
so yeah i did that a few times um
not very proud of them situations though
what do you think were the worst
experiences in
prison um i've watched someone's head
get squashed in a door killed
and someone hold some of the 10-pound
canteen
so the lord punched him as he punched
him the light fell on the floor and as
he's fell on the floor the lad who
punched him so i said get out my cell
and but he
fell on the floor and he's headed
caught between the door and as he's
pushed the door he slammed the door and
he crushed his skull on the floor
and he was dead
so when i got out of prison when i was
20
i'm just stopping people in cars saying
my mate in the park's got the best drugs
and i'm getting paid for that so that's
how i'm carrying on my crack cocaine
addiction and then i've got the working
girls coming to me and saying marv who's
got the best crap but i wasn't really a
drug deal i was just a crackhead i was
just trying to get a little bit of
shekels off everyone who's selling drugs
you know i'm trying to get customers for
them and whatnot
so how long your crack addiction lasted
for
i had a 20-year crack addiction
i
fell in love with it
there was nothing like it on earth it's
the most strongest drug in the world
it's the most addictive drug on the
planet for a reason
what happened when i was 33 i was still
a raging crack addict
33 years of age new year's eve i'm
riding down the road i've just come out
of prison
i see this guy we know and this guy
punches girls puts them on the beat
forces them to smoke crack
forces them into prostitution
so i see him with some young girl and i
say to him yeah what are you doing with
her mate don't you dare take her onto
that beat down there so he's going oh no
whoa i won't i'm just there i'm just
having her drinks because it was new
year's eve bear in mind so he's gotten
in the news agents in the shop so i said
to the girl yeah take my number if you
need me for anything phone me
like because he's trouble stay away from
him
so um
she takes my number half an hour later
rings her back and says you're all right
so she's crying she said okay he's just
beat me up in a gay village you need to
come and help me so i went and rid on my
little bike so i'll go and get her
uh start talking to her and find out
that she's only 18. she's having a bit
of trouble at home and stuff
and she's with this guy and this guy's
much older i said so he needs to get
away from him he will get you addicted
to drugs and he will get you on the beat
before you can even realize what's
happening
so uh
that was that leave it next day i rinser
again say i will you what you're doing
so she said he's beating me up i need to
get away from him he's beat me up
because i left with you last night
so
i've oh i'm somebody's staying at my
niece's house i've just come out of
prison i ain't got a secure address i'm
in a little spare bedroom so i throw my
niece up and i say look i just met this
girl and she's only young she's not a
drug addict do you mind if she stays in
my room with me she went don't you dare
bring no scruffs here so i said i want a
promise so anyway bro
brought her to the house
so she's staying at the house i get
recalled to prison i'm wanted for a
license breach so i get recalled to
prison
while i'm in prison
she phones me up from prison and says
he's just levered me
in on a bus so i say to her go to the
police
so she said no it's grassing i said it's
not grassy so i convinced her to go to
court against this man and get him five
and a half years so we got locked up for
that
so that was very empowering and i've
been with the girl ever since and now
we've been together for 15 years
so every time i'm smoking crack for
hours
i can't wait for it to go so i can go
back to living a normal life because i
won't smoke crack in her house i won't
smoke crack near her so
i'm going to the house
i've got no crap i'm waking up the next
morning
all i can think about is crack so i'm
running away i'm running and running all
the time and she's following me to crack
houses saying you've got to stop you've
got to stop doing this like you're not
happy and i knew i wasn't happy
but i was working with an adoption
agency because i was adopted
and they wouldn't open me adoption file
for me she kept saying to me um when you
get off drugs we will help we will go to
the next step
so i wanted to get clean so i could
find my birth family
when i was clean my adoption agents at
work i said right you're ready to open
your adoption file
so i went away so happy thinking yes i'm
gonna find my mum finally at last
two weeks later she phones me up
i walk in she gives me my mum's death
certificate she says i'm so sorry i
couldn't tell you before
so they said to me we've got the best
news in the world
your mum's gone but we have found your
birth mom's family
so i said all right then somebody said
we're going to have to send all your
previous convictions to them
and then they've got to decide whether
they want to get to know me or not
so i
wait
so i'm dead nervous thinking they're
going to want to know me or not and my
auntie contacts me
my auntie contacts them and says yeah
i want a relationship with him so what
had happened was when my mum gave me
away
how much how my mum how my auntie found
out about me was she started seeing them
a lot called marvin and moon found out
now my mum called me marvin at birth so
my adoptive mom never changed it out of
respect for her she put lee at the front
but she never called me lee she always
called me marvie and that's how they
found out yeah
i
i have just had the most amazing time
like they've been beautiful towards me
really nice people greek cypriot
very family orientated
loving family very tight-knit
looking back at your life and everything
you've been through if you could change
one thing what would you what would you
change
[Music]
my mum signing that certificate to give
me away
yeah that was it i would rather
with my mum
then
whatever happened to me because whatever
happened to my mum
is a sad tale
but my my life was i needed her i needed
my mum i went searching for all my life
i just couldn't find her i tried so hard
and i wanted to find her when i was on
drugs but i didn't feel i felt i didn't
deserve to
look for a while i was a drug addict you
know what i mean i didn't feel like
she'd want to know me or anything like
that so
i decided i wouldn't wouldn't try and
find her while i was on drugs but the
minute i got off drugs
i was ready i was ready to do this
i missed out on living a normal fam
normal life i wasn't a member of normal
member of society when i was
stealing and committing crime i used to
go into the city center and i wouldn't
walk down the main fur affair i'd be
walking down every little back street
and entry possible because i never felt
worthier to be a member of that humanity
i'd never felt that it'd ever give me
anything good it treated me really bad
so i never felt like it i was part of it
i always felt like it was a different
part of it i'm at peace i've just had a
baby
my girlfriend
had a baby two years old he is now
happier than i've ever been in my life
[Music]
and as they were walking around me
one of them would
punch me headbutt me as this was going
on the guy was looking down at me asking
me questions and i became convinced that
i wasn't going to leave there in one
piece